I kind of worked on statistical methods
and then I was very lucky at early out
of my career to have some great
collaborators and some some work that i
did with Ken singleton started getting a
lot of attention and and I guess at that
point in time was the first time I had
on some feeling that this is an
important research agenda and maybe it
was nineteen eighty-five when Kenneth
and I were given the first prize Ragnar
fish was the first Nobel laureate in
economics and so the kind of every
society has this prize called the first
prize and so at a fairly young age I was
I was able to share that I guess that
was an indicator that the work was
getting some attention I remember being
very much kind of enthusiastic and
excited by the research but it was very
hard to tell that how you know which
portions of the research we're going to
command the biggest attention in fact it
even now when I work on research
projects yeah sometimes they get very
little attention sometimes they get a
lot and I mean while I'm doing it it's
not always so easy to tell which are the
ones I'll have the bigger influence